on atterrit la review on ne bouge pas
pendant les gardes
c'est bien vous cherchez un moment ça a
été west et anouk vous pensez a cours en
ce moment là tu avoues la c5 ou ça casse
quand vous vous regardez le matin mon
miroir vous vous dites quoi je me
regarde mais je n'ai pas mes lunettes
ça va quand elle vous pleurez pour la
dernière fois je serai ya pas tellement
longtemps j'ai vu un programme je crois
c'est rareté sur des enfants
palestiniens et israéliens et deux mois
à moi je sais pas et qui est évidemment
là où ils étaient et ils ont passé une
journée tous ensemble ils ont joué comme
des mômes et après sont rentrés chez eux
et après les gosses ont dit c'est
terrible quand on sera grand va
peut-être se tuer ça ça m'a complètement
sa trousse un môme était super
formidable c'était des mots s'il était
pareil et ça m'a bouleversé c'est à dire
si la vie était à refaire vous feriez
quoi pas pareil peut-être que je serai
consciente malheureuse ou que l'argent a
quand même une certaine importance
jamais fait attention à l'argent fou
quand un petit peu faire attention
peut-être sinon j'ai pas trop à me
plaindre
si vous restez 24 heures à vivre feriez
quoi pendant ces 24 heures
donc je pars tout de suite à honolulu
parce que gagne un jour
qu'est ce que la vie vous a appris la
tolérance
quand j'ai posé la question de chance
elle pour finir ses traditionnels et
dieu dans tout ça
je crois qu'en ce soit moi il doit être
parti en vacances